remember over the summer when I told you
that there were rumblings of a Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson resignation that
was true apparently and we now know more
about the context and also about why it
allegedly didn't happen this is a
fascinating leak which just to be
totally upfront is being 100% denied by
Donald Trump at this point according to
NBC News Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson was openly calling President
Trump a [ __ ] after a July 20th meeting
at the Pentagon according to multiple
senior Trump administration officials
Rex Tillerson reportedly called Trump a
[ __ ] in front of members of the entire
national security team as well as
cabinet members three senior officials
said to NBC imagine being a fly on the
wall for that one right so he called
Trump a [ __ ] we were hearing rumblings
of a resignation why didn't the
resignation of Rex Tillerson happen
apparently vice president Mike Pence
talked him out of it
Pence is also denying that this report
is true the Boy Scout speech debacle
played a role according to this report
Tillerson was once a leader of the Boy
Scouts of America and apparently when
Donald Trump showed up and gave that
bizarre rambling embarrassing political
speech to the Boy Scouts it was sort of
a high point in the tensions between
Tillerson and Trump and exactly as
always happens after these reports the
White House initially declines to
comment but then Trump goes out on
Twitter and says the entire thing is
fake you know I have a hard time
believing the denials I have a really
hard time believing the denials and Rex
Tillerson spoke this morning and while
he reaffirmed his commitment to the job
which means nothing by the way he did
not deny having called Donald Trump a
[ __ ] and you'll remember that incident
where Rex Tillerson was asked about the
impact of Donald Trump's tweets or
comments until erson said something
along the lines of President speaks for
himself that is an indication that
things are not going particularly well
between the Secretary of State and the
president are things going better now
it's unclear clearly Tillerson didn't
resign today he said that he is
committed to the job but looking at
Trump's recent tweets there is every
indication that there is still tension I
mean just in the last couple of days
Donald Trump tweeted in the
midst of Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson saying he thought he was
making headway with North Korea Trump
tweeted I told Rex Tillerson our
wonderful Secretary of State that he is
wasting his time trying to negotiate
with little rocket man save your energy
Rex will do what has to be done
this might seem minor but think about
what it means
Tillerson said publicly that he was
making headway with North Korea
not long ago really important job for
the Secretary of State right try to
de-escalate potentially nuclear involved
crises with an unfriendly nation and
Trump goes public and says I told Rex
not even to bother with this entire
thing Tillerson is a greedy oligarch
with ties to Russia but he's not a [ __ ]
right and he's clearly aware of the
utter disaster that is the Trump
administration when it comes to foreign
policy and international diplomacy which
directly impacts Tillerson his Secretary
of State again Tillerson says I reaffirm
my commitment to the role that's like
when Trump says he has full confidence
in someone and two days later they end
up fired or forced to resign so I've
been saying the next to go is going to
be Steven minuchin for the civil or
similar travel type stuff that Tom Price
ultimately resigned over or maybe Jared
Kushner for the endless covering up of
foreign contacts and private email
addresses maybe Tillerson could be next
either by resignation or by firing and
if that were to happen it's a major
major incident right having a Secretary
of State resign or be fired in the first
nine months of an administration is bad
enough having your Secretary of State
resign or be fired after a dozen 22
dozen prominent people in your
administration have already been fired
or resigned
it's the exact type of embarrassing
chaos that Russia would want to fomented
in the United States if they were
actually involved in the 2016 election
which of course every indication is that
they were the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as $1 per month and every dollar helps
to soup
or the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad